our next talk is by mirin Kim tan her
PhD from the Seoul National University
and then did a post doctorate at UCSD
and she's now a professor at the UT
Houston with the Health Science Center
and she's gonna tell us about the I -
competition and applications of morphic
encryption it's great honor to give a
talk about how yet introduce their
recent progress of morphine Krypton for
protecting genomic privacy this project
is supported by a National Institute of
Health and this is joint work with
shoutings young arrived how much a duty
health and I should cherish asking Wong
at Indiana University and Luciano
Machado and tongue Tinku at UCSD you
know the cost of full genome sequencing
traps so fast on 2008 code three billion
and it fell to one thousand dollars from
2014 and this allows researchers to
access to large genomic data sets and
data sharing is of great importance
importance to data analysis to speed up
this coverage and promote research
actually on 2014 NIH genomic NIH issued
a genomic data sharing policy that
allows the use of human genomic data for
research and the use of cloud computing
service for storage and analysis but you
know genomic data are very sensitive and
it contains a large amount of personal
information actually on 2015 the former
President Barack Obama spoke about the
precision medicine initiative and and he
encouraged biomedical data sharing and
he also mentioned
that we are going to make sure about the
patient privacy and instead
unsurprisingly the iris sever the
identification attacks for example Lin
ET arrow they showed larger than 55
snips can identify a single person so
there may be a genetic discrimination
duty identifiable information and people
are more worried about that maybe
sensitive information might be
disclosure due to inappropriate use of
their data so it's a great fear of
unknown and recently there are some
regulations from several countries and
HIPAA is one of them which is for health
information regulation though for United
States and it recommends to remove the
identifiers in the database such as name
zip code and etc and in the case of
Europe you recently made some data
privacy laws and it goes for anyone or
any company in EU member state and it
claims several rights such as the rise
to be important the rise to be racial
and so on and the most important thing
is that it this privacy protection law
recommends a kind of technical privacy
protection so it is getting more
challenged to ensure how to provide how
to ensure the security and privacy of
the data actually you know there are
several privacy technologies for secure
computation for example multi-party
computation in decay or and differential
privacy and among them among the various
age among them AG is it can be
considered as one of the promising
solutions for the secure competition and
actually our AG community have regular
standard
in meetings to discuss the underlying
security and applications and API and as
another community effort they're having
a competition to apply a morphic
encryption to biomedical challenges and
it was sponsored by the NIH and several
companies such as I do Lumina and platon
and since 2014
this competition has been motivated by
your word by medical challenges and many
crypto experts and biomedical
researchers have participated this
competition and the participants were
asked to develop practical and legal
solutions for privacy preserving genomic
analysis and we have demonstrated the
visibility's and applicability of
security Nomi data analysis using a chi
and including as well as multi-party
computation or different privacy and as
Jax and especially in on 2015 this
competition was reported in several
media such as nature news and genome web
and dawa news in South Korea and
Microsoft Research news since 2015 the
workshop is getting bigger and bigger as
seen in this number and more people from
around the world are participating this
competition and every year our
organizers receive dozens of submissions
from university to industries let me
briefly introduce to tell what was such
challenge in 2015 two tasks was to
perform genome analysis such as
comparison of DNA sequence there are
also NPC track and in 2016 it was kind
of testing genetic disease unencrypted
genome data and since 2000
17 the task challenge were more machine
learning based analysis for example on
2017 the task was to build a logistic
regression model that can predict a
breast cancer and 2018 it was to perform
genome-wide Association studies over
encrypted genomes and last year the task
was to predict missing genome data using
trade model and 2000 and last year was
the peak year for the registration of 80
track yeah it was it was there are four
five four teams resistor or discount for
80 track and in this talk I will explain
how different eighty schemes were used
and optimized to so this part these
particles problems the tasks of 2015 and
15 was to compute Hamming distance and
approximate at a distance so we can
securely obtain the similarity of two
DNA strings and on each DNA variant we
need to check if two there to Ellie's
are equal or not so the efficiency was
determined by how to express equality
circuit actually at that time we only
have the most how hopefully use 80
schemes was busy V and P Fe and their
scheme encrypt integer so for example
the best solutions for Hamming distance
used if arimathea param elderly theorem
using the fact that the message space is
defined as their prime field and the
best solutions for a distance expressed
equality and comparison circuit as
binary operations for example if yeah
let's say last key is the plaintext
modulus then when
and when he is prime then if a and B are
the elements of this prime field C sub P
then the Equality circuit is expressed
using this power of P minus 1 and if P
is 2 is very special case of the first
first case first example and it can be a
little more simpler it's just there's no
multiplication if you just come just
check the equality between 1 bits and if
you want to compare it check the
Equality multi-multi bits then we may we
compare it speak we checked a quality on
each beats and multiply the results
together so the performance was that it
takes around 8 minutes to computer and
it had to Hamming distance on 100 kg
comes and 3 it takes three minutes to
compute approximate at a distance of 10
k sequence and 2016 the task was kind of
applications to security netic testing
on your with your file so given a list
up to 10 and 100 km mutants the task was
to encrypt the whole dataset using a chi
and enable the data owner to carry the
data set for the presence of the
specific genetic mutants
so it's car is sort of string match and
the past solution was also it was used a
similar approach of the bitwise
representation like 2015 solution so it
take around one minute to carry one hour
to perform one carry in 50 with your
files and each file has one 100k loud
and on 2017 the participants were asked
you to build a logistic regression model
and the data set consists of the
phenotypes for the cancer so if it has
cancered and it has it it has plus one
and otherwise it has minus one and we
also have genotypes which represent the
existence of the mutant are the specific
snips so it's not the real DNA sequence
it just binary values so it it is 1 if
it contains mutant and otherwise it's
true 0 so it's sort so it's the
phenotype and genotype they are kind of
your binary and the goal is to find a
poop find a good predictor vector beta
with support and really relationship
between the predictor variable X and the
lobe code of the event such that the
response is 1 so if they represent a
linear predictor with a probability than
this the previous equation is equivalent
to the following so the left-hand side
of the equation is called the destroy
dysfunction and therefore it is cut this
model that's why it's model it's called
of this regression and obviously
function look look like that so we can
simplify this problem by changing it to
meet some minimizing problems such as
minimizing the negative log likelihood
cost function and in machine learning
Bates machine or machine learning
approach the gradient descent method is
widely used for this kind of
optimization to my judgment problem so
the idea is very simple before and start
with some initial guess and then kept
changing the Moodle parameter
reduce the cost until we hopefully
approach a minimum so the update rule
can be written as follows so it's for at
each iteration we take steps some steps
proportional to the negative of the
gradient of the functions at the current
point so gradient descent is kind of
first-order iterative optimization
algorithm for finding a local minimum
and on the other hand there is another
method to use second-order iterative
algorithm which is called Newton method
and as you see the second derivative
which is called Hessian matrix and we
need to compute the inverse of the
Hessian matrix so it's not easy not at
all not easy at all for the evaluation
so the first challenge of so the first
challenge of the evaluation of the
gradient descent is that the derivative
term is computed as the sigmoid value of
the inner product between the old model
parameter and the input variable X and
you know as in this figure the sigmoid
is an analytic function and Hz only
support addition and multiplication over
encrypted data so this means that Hz
cannot naturally support this evaluation
of the sigmoid function and there are
another challenge such that the
competition that this computation is
actually real number arithmetic and
since the training algorithm are
recursive so the multiplicative daffs
grows grows linearly with a number of
iteration and in practice we need a few
iterations to get meaningful results so
first let us take a look at how to
approximate the the Sigma 2 polynomial
the first one is Taylor series expansion
and this method is why do we use
several years but it's not a good
candidate for approximation because it's
just global up just the co approximation
near some point and in the ITEX
competition there are three different
polynomial approximation proposed and
the first one is to use person expansion
or we can use them you can find a good
global approximation which minimized the
main error of the target function and
estimation or we can use the infinite
norm infinite error and seen in this
figure approximate approximating
polynomial with a small degree for
example the risk-free degree 3 or degree
7 or D if I as far as member it was
degree 3 and the approximate polynomial
with very small degree is very close to
signature will sigmoid on certain ranges
and here are the results
we actually evaluated 6 submitted
solutions and I want to briefly
introduce introduce four solutions
the first one is proposed submitted by
EPFL and they use PFE scheme and they
use person expansion percent expansions
for sigmoid approximation and they just
applied one iteration of gradient
descent and kayuu Lubin they also use
benefit scheme with Taylor series
expansion for sigmoid approximation and
surprisingly they adapt one iteration of
newton method and you know u2 method
hack include matrix inversion so first
they approximate the second derivative
term to some diagonal map title matrix
and then with this approximation they
only need to compute the inverse of its
diagonal element to construct we are
of the second derivative so and then
they approximate the inverse of these
multiple numbers by using Newton laughs
reference approximate method anyway
anyway if AFL and Kuo Bell then they use
PFA scheme and reactive King they just
support integer integer encoding
encoding or integer encryption so they
first scale real number to integer and
after some computation the message can
be very large so they have to issued
such a large plant XPath and it results
in some downgrade in performance and
[Music]
Microsoft also used BFF scheme and with
minimax approximation and the key
feature of their solution is that they
approach applied the bootstrapping
techniques and this step and as in the
previous talks this boutique shopping
technique is usually used to reduce the
noise after computation so we can
perform arbitrary computation on
encrypted data but they modified for
disrupting in order to models with a
floral flooring operation in one step so
I think in their protocol they perform
bootstrapping
right after each multiplication so that
they handled the flooring they can
handle flooring operation as well as put
a strap in and they addressed a concern
about growth of message and error
compared to the fafl and Kayla boo
but at the time the performance of
bootstrapping was not so good I think
yeah so as far as member each time it's
time and to each iteration of gradient
descent takes around 20 minutes and but
anyway it's very meaningful solutions to
extend the computation cost linearly
with a arbitrary number of it
and the final solution was proposed
submitted by Sony University and UCSD
and yeah they solution was built on the
ckk a scheme and you know as in the
previous previous talk yet CKK has came
support built-in routing operation very
naturally so they can they could take
advantage of take advantage of the
rescaling operation and they use then
use this clear approximation and they
could repeat seven iterations of
gradient descent and the experiment with
all show that logistic regression
training of our data set with 14k
concert it was 14k 14k examples with 18
features can be finished within 10
minutes and on 2018 the task was to
investigate it associations of the
genotypes and phenotypes by building the
logistic regression model so it means
that on its net variant we predict
binary response Y based on the predictor
variables of the covariance including a
weight and height and there's no type
sleep at in a time phenotype a sub at a
subset J so actually we want to learn
better coefficient of the snips of the
corresponding snips and then see how
different they this better coefficient
is from zero so we if it is
significantly large then we can say that
the snip at this position has a large
effect on the effect that it is but so
denial method is to repeat this
regression model training for each
individual snip and the number of snips
is 15 K so but
Smith at a time is too costly forget
maybe we can estimate it in the law in
2017 it takes around 10 minutes to build
one Lotus regression model of dimension
16 so maybe it takes around two and a
half minutes to build a one model of the
dimension 4 and we repeat 15k times and
then maybe it takes around 20 more than
20 days so it's invisible
so the IDIS organiser recommended to use
very easy friendly lady friend logistic
regression model which is called semi
parallel position regression and main
idea is that we can assume that the
parameters or covariance will stay
nearly the same for all snips so we can
divide two steps the first step is just
pre-trained a model on KO barrier Kaveri
attacks and you know this covariant has
very small dimension just 3d map just
the cup number of column is 3 and and we
can't just compute a build up model just
one time and after that after after that
using the trained model as a starting
point we can find the model parameters
of each individual snips more accurately
maybe in parallel so we need we need so
it was recommended to use the Newton
method for the seconds that's for in
order to obtain the more accurate
parameters and let's remind the how
Newton method was would like and it has
it has the matrix inversion and it was
not easy to it was not easy to become to
be evaluated so let us take a look how
its solutions address this problem
yeah here is the first here's the
problem and first I want to say
surprisingly all the teams you see
kick-ass game or it's combination with
Jeff H scheme and I think this is
because we need real number computation
over encrypted data and and as far as we
know the C key K is the best solutions
for the real number approximation of
your number computation and so the first
step of the yeah for the first step is
just build a Lutece regression model or
comparing acts and the first step is
very similar to the last year 2017 Ida's
task
so this steps between the submitted
solutions are very similar they they
adapted previous winning solutions of
2017 and as I mentioned in the previous
slide the main challenging part is how
to compute metrics inverse so duality
duality company and so much university
and UCSD they complete matrix inversion
from the computation of the educated and
determinant so the main advantage of
this representation is that they are
expressed as close one just consists of
addition and multiplication so it can be
calculate in an efficient way
and tfh team efficiently evaluated
Sycamore evaluation inside gate to
distracting as ilaria's talk and and as
far as a member they convert ETFs came
in to basically as Kim cipher tags when
the morphing of evaluation of multiple
messages is needed and wanted him and
UCSD they used the RNs variant of ckk a
scheme so they showed good performance
than others in terms of the timing and
accuracy
and on 2019 the task was to perform the
security petition on encrypted genomic
data using a strain deplaned train
claimed model and genomic imputation is
kind of very basic tasks in G wasps
which leverage the correlation between
the genotypes of the existing variants
to estimate genotypes of missing variant
and then and this participant were
provided were given poured if four
different types of genome data and in
the training phase they they were asked
to build a model that can predict a
target genotypes using the text
genotypes and for each snip variant
maybe they can select the closet the
number of the predictors in the target
data set as the training data and
training data and in the testing phase
if after they train the model and in the
testing in the testing phase they
encrypt tagged this the whole TOC data
and then predict the genotypes using the
trained model whether it's encrypted
check till types and so make sure that
the demo data the whole data is
encrypted but the model which is given
as front plate and we performed
evaluation over encrypted data and the
tap data was kind of yet 250 samples
with 9500 snips and attacked the target
snips it has the same number of samples
but smaller snip variant and it's team
use different imputation model for
example something yeah
a star and if you fail and chaff a steam
they adapt the goddess to Russian models
so they train the body they train the
model using the distribution model or
some team use convolution neural network
kind of more complex model and so much
university they use one hidden layer
you're a network model and it's team
optimized the airplane model while
considering various number of that
causes predictor for example some team
consider 100 causes predictor and some
team uses just 32 closet predictor and
this competition this competition is
pretty easier than the last two years
but the fuss the fast solutions it was
by TFS team and it takes so takes only
less than four minutes for the whole the
whole securing petition and I think is
really showed applicability and
scalability of the aging and in the few
years this Americans progress of the of
a HD have been made towards security and
improving the efficiency and I hope that
maybe we will push the frontier and
facilitate its continued advancing the
secure solutions thank you for attention
[Applause]
any questions from you
so I have a question maybe a little
higher level question during the course
of all of these competitions is there
like a picture of specific type of
computations or maybe specific
application domains well home Orphic
encryption seems more useful than others
you mean compared to other cryptographic
I mean just you know places where you'd
expect to see action may be commercial
or at least public secretary use of
homomorphic encryption used for things
other than competitions and science
fairs or things like that but actually -
for things that people want to do in
their daily lives or in institutions
want to do is there is there any kind of
picture that emerges out of these
competitions I'm sorry but I don't have
any yeah big picture but I so in
particular
I mean other was like public policy or
public health bodies that seriously
consider using any of these techniques
from the I - competition are in their
normal operations are the projects going
to that direction I think they just they
just starting it is starting to have
some interest in secure technology so
not I think not ready for there may be
the weirder cliches real applications of
techniques but I think the more and more
people may be for example NIH you know
they have some more they're there
that project of how to apply a chi or
how to apply NBC to the biomedical
challenges so maybe I I hope that maybe
after 10 10 years maybe there is some
more like regulations though maybe we
can't we have to use 2 we use any
progress techniques for in order to
provide the secure data analysis but not
ready but maybe yeah maybe within in the
future thank you any more questions
so in that case let's think me run again
and we will meet in Surrey I think there
are some questions that are coming in
through DNA oh sorry yeah yeah the first
question is the source code for the Ida
submissions made publicly available
somewhere didn't find on the IDIS
website Thanks I think it depends on the
it's teams for example our team provided
the paper with the public of the
available source court so it maybe you
can find some you can find it in the
yeah in the you can find it in Google
and a second question is that how does
Ida's state assess eyes compared to the
pure word genomic data sizes mmm
it depends on the task but in my
experience it's really difficult to get
the real data so but anytime but our our
organizer and try to find
the real world yeah we're the real data
and but some some people say it's not
your data is not the big size compared
to the real data set but I think it is
enough to show the scalability of the
feasibility of HD and the third question
is will I just take place in this year
will there be your AG task hmm yeah sure
yeah we we are preparing a cheat track
and maybe we can yeah post posting maybe
next month or yeah actually there's
because it's because of the copied 19 so
yeah maybe yeah you can see you can you
can check it maybe next next month and
the last question is that other than
computation time and memory is energy
cost also considered as a metric mm not
so much in the evaluation which was just
evaluated the computation time including
encryption and evaluation and decryption
kind of tau and - and performance and we
evaluated we are uses memory or and
sometimes we just we just we also
evaluate accuracy of the model for
example this regression model or yeah
but not energy cost and the other
question is that do you accept any kind
of solutions like MBC and different
privacy or D or our new focus on F 80
mostly oh yeah it's good custard hmm
in this talk I just address I just
introduced a tea trap but but as in the
previous and
the view first slide I hope there is
also some tract about NBC and different
privacy and asked you acts so you can
find it and the last question is that
would it would it be possible to give
access to previous year data set I think
yeah you have to ask today I just
organizer and I think it might be public
available if you yeah you should ask you
either sympathizer yeah including me
yeah okay maybe I'll just ask one more
question I merely related to that I
think it would maybe partially the
question is about publishing the results
at least the current capabilities for
morphic encryption with respect to a
given problem
I mean maybe removing the information
about you know well the winning teams
but more what are the current
capabilities of homework encryption and
having those results publicly available
might be beneficial just when we
especially when we talk about
applications of fhe what are their
current abilities maybe from that
perspective sharing some that
information publicly might be useful
okay thank you we will reconvene in five
minutes